good morning John last week Katherine
and I celebrated our sixth anniversary
by trying to get out of the smoke and
heading into northern Montana we design
D&D characters we went into Glacier
National Park we watched a vh1 special
in the top 100 hits of the 90s which
kind of made me disappointed in my
generation we had a nice dinner out on
the deck of our hotel room unfortunately
there was a deck above us so we were on
a deck and there was a deck above us and
we can hear everything they were saying
so we knew that they could hear
everything we were saying it was a
little awkward until one of the people
up there spilt their beer and it poured
through the slats onto us and our dinner
and then it was a lot awkward and I
couldn't like correctly handle the
situation I guess build Billy drinks in
my life and so of wheel I'm not a very
careful person and I probably wouldn't
have been any more careful than that guy
over there it's kind of no one to be mad
at that doesn't make you feel any less
mad about having some strange beer
poured all over your carefully cooked
kielbasa that maybe you think of deer
because I almost hit a deer on the way
to whitefish a cute one like little with
spot and the reason I didn't hit the
deer the one reason is because I did not
leave the gas station two seconds
earlier if I had I would have run right
into the deer because they wouldn't have
had time to stop that's the only reason
that made me think of how like every
time we drive over 30 miles an hour
anyway we're basically in an alternative
universe somewhere killing squirrels and
deer and dogs and cats and terrible
things that would make us feel terrible
but we don't feel bad about getting in a
car and driving unless it's one of those
times when we hit the deer I didn't do
anything different than the guy who did
hit the deer that day we are the same
but he has to feel bad about it and I
don't that's not fair and that made me
think of how we punished murderers more
than we punished attempted murderers
you're rewarding them for being bad it's
the thing they wanted to do at that
point it's just a roll of the d20 to see
if they get a critical hit but just
because they happen to roll one they
don't have to go to jail that makes me
think of a bunch of other ways that our
justice system is kind of screwed up and
that makes me want to think about
something else like how later in that
same weekend after we got the beer off
Kathryn and I took a chairlift up to the
top of big mountain and it was kind of
scary
why squeaking Katherine's you don't want
to see what's back there
no I gotta draw the camera look we're on
a chairlift going to the top of what's
it called it's called Big Mountain it's
a big mountain let me play a lot of
Minecraft it kind of makes me want to
get a pickaxe out see if I could find
some ore we are a little bit afraid of
heights Katherine and I maybe Katherine
tiny bit more than me who wants one on a
ferris wheel in Missoula and we're like
this is gonna be a great idea you know
Montana sized ferris wheel not the eye
of London or whatever what's that called
the London Eye nothing the eye of London
we got like a third of the way up I
hadn't even looked that way yet that was
the first time I did that that was
there's a lot of nothing back there as
we walked the four mile path from the
top of Big Mountain back to the
chairlift I kept thinking about paths
which makes sense because I was walking
on a path about how man-made
constructions can actually make nature
more beautiful as long as they're
informed by the nature that they're a
part of about how the edge between
habitats can often be the most
productive areas of an ecosystem about
how a path is a communal creation
created by thousands of footsteps of men
and women and animals and how a path
indicates both a journey and a
destination and how those things are
always better if you have someone that
you love to share them with John I have
chosen a punishment as well though I
have had to make it gluten-free in order
to accommodate my terrible excuse for
coal in other news the Lizzie Bennet
diaries just hit its fiftieth episode
thank you all so much for helping that
project survive and thrive it's really
great to see people enjoying it and in
my season 5 recap of the guild which
will be going live on geek & sundry I
talk faster than I have ever talked
before so that's something to see links
in the doobly-doo John thank you for
being awesome and I will see you on
Tuesday